And everybody, this is Dr. Cutters. We're in the step five.
Start healing your barriers, and I do want to say it. I don't think I added this to other stuff.
So you can do these things concurrently. Of course, you can't do too much at one time.
You've got to go slow and you've got to take steps and you've got to take little bite sized pieces and baby steps are okay to take.
So don't overwhelm yourself.
Um, no, if you like a lot of people again, you started this journey a long time before adding this course and learning this information.
So, um, you might be farther out of the road and you may be even gotten passed all of this.
You really need help, um, from a professional to help get some testing and go to the next step.
That's okay. So everybody's at wherever they're starting point is.
So this step is about healing your barriers.
And I'll tell you right now, this is an ever-ending process you don't ever, we did a gut healing protocol and now I'm good.
Okay, I'm sorry, but you're constantly damaging your gut.
If you live, you're constantly damaging your barriers.
It's, it's a constant battle. It's a something, it's a lifestyle of working on your barriers.
Your gut barrier, your lung barrier, your blood barrier, your three main barriers that we're talking about.
So, um, it's not something you did something, a gut healing protocol and now you're done.
It just doesn't work that way.
It's just something you have to be constantly working on.
Why? Because it's constantly being damaged.
You know, you are exposed to all this stuff on a daily basis.
Goodness sakes, you're sleeping on a bed with fire retardants.
You just bought a new couch wonderful.
You lay down on it, it's filled with fire retardant chemicals.
There's radiation exposure, PCBs, chemicals, benzene, pesticides, herbicides, you know, things that you can't even pronounce that are damaging our barriers.
This is causing a high degree of oxidative stress to our body and the first thing it damages is their cells of what it comes in contact with.
So, if it's going through your lung, it's damaging your lung barriers.
It's getting through your, through into the blood vessels.
It's going to damage your blood brain barrier, the astrocytes that make up the blood brain barrier are going to be damaged.
It's going to get in your brain, cause brain inflammation, possibly microglial damage and worst-case scenario you develop neural antibodies.
If you're swallowing these things, you're exposed to them orally, it can damage your esophageal barrier, it can damage your barrier and your mouth.
It can upset your microbiota.
It's going to damage your epithelial cells that line, your intestinal tract, and when you start to have that happen, you end up with leak-out issues.
So, it's just a constant, ever-ending battle.
You are constantly exposed to this stuff.
It is a process that you just cannot grow tired of because you're constantly have to be working on this.
So, don't get weary.
It's just part of our lifestyle, okay?
Let's first talk about the blood-brain barrier.
It's very, very important.
I will say if you haven't watched my video on neural inflammation and microglial-private and highly recommend,
let you do that.
It really helps you understand the mechanisms of what happens in your brain and what your blood-brain barrier is really made up.
We're just going to be simple.
Here are some of the things that compromise our blood-brain barrier, what we just spoke about.
But some of the symptoms that we lead to, that could tell us that we have blood-brain barrier,
issues is memory loss, brain fog, depression, sadness, emotional swings, mood swings,
brain fatigue, headaches, gosh, it just goes on and on and on, I could have just listed on and on and on here.
But then it went part of the brain-in-effects, so if you have chemicals across your blood-brain barrier
and whether you have or have not, microglial damage, if these chemicals cause inflammation in a certain part of the brain,
that's going to cause certain symptoms, if it affects your pride, although your pridele is mainly your sensory input.
So that's what input from the rest of your body, the a-fairant fibers from the body.
So if I stubbed my toe, where does it hurt?
It hurts at my toe.
Well, really, you hit your toe, you'd fire it up, let's say it's my right toe, fire it up.
The nerve pathway, up, crossed through my spine, to the other side, goes up to my brain, fires to my left side of my pridele,
but tells my pridele that there's pain there, so really I'm feeling pain from my right toe stub in my left pridele.
Well, likewise, if I have inflammation of my left pridele, I could have right toe pain.
So sometimes the pain that we have in our body, let's say if I have right knee-paid, it could be caused from arthritis in my knee.
It could be caused from an injury to my knee, it could be caused from local inflammation in my knee,
but it could be caused from inflammation in my left parietal lobe.
This is where it gets a little complicated, but you've got to follow me through this, because this is what you see with a lot with chronic autoimmune patients,
chronic Lyme patients, chronic mold patients, they have these strange symptoms that go for one spot to the other spot and seemingly doesn't make sense.
How can my knee be swollen on the right side of it? It hurts so much, I can't even walk on it, and I wake up the next day and that's not even an issue whatsoever.
It doesn't even hurt, it's like it's miraculously healed, but now I can't move my left elbow. What in the heck is going on?
Well, that's a side that there's compromise in the blood barrier, there's inflammation that's going on in the brain, in this case, the parietal lobe,
but you could have the same thing happen in the frontal lobe, but you could have all sorts of executive function issues, memory loss,
can't process data, not thinking correctly, just psychosis and neurosis, that are seemingly unexplainable,
that can be caused for inflammation in the brain. This, again, a point to data that has come out, that has, that millions of dollars were spent through the post-concussive studies,
that have really, really helped functional doctors, if you really take that information that you decipher and use it for your patients,
because it shows serious mood disorders, serious personality changes all due to inflammation in the brain.
So, you can assess this, you can assess at least blood-brained antibodies through the Syrex Array 20, you can go deeper into the Array, Syrex Array 7X,
which tests for full neuronal antibodies to see if you have other antibodies to sell to a brain tissue,
but really, based on tonal self-assessed with symptom patterns, you can go, I need some help for my blood-brained barrier,
and to decrease inflammation of my brain. So, here's some key things that you want to do, you want to support,
definitely support glutathione, you definitely want to support neural inflammation, that's a key component,
remember I said in other videos, that that is, what all those studies came down to is increasing flavonoids that decreased inflammation of the brain,
there wasn't even any medication intervention that helped with inflammation of the brain, a damaged blood-brained barrier,
and I'll give down to nutritional use of flavonoids, and we'll talk about them in just a second,
it's supporting vascular dynamics with edithelial nitric oxide, so they support.
So, specific nutraceuticals that are best for neuroinflammation and helping with blood-brained barrier permeability will have greater videos on this,
specifically, but I just want to give you this overview, glutathione, liposomal glutathione is always the best glutathione,
resveratrol, and it resveratrol, you have to take throughout the day because it has such a short half-life,
curcumin, curcumin is a key component for most of our patients with cancer, I mean, it's a super antioxidant, anti-inflammatory,
anti-cancer nutrient that's just, you know, a godsend, the apigins, the, from salary and parsley,
the, I'm not going to read all these off here, so there's a bunch of different nutrients that could be so, so helpful.
With that top five star things, I would add EGCG from green T-extract, and then your Boswellia,
any of the, any of the flavonoids really could be put in there, so are just so beneficial to decrease inflammation in the brain.
Next category would be the lung epithelial barrier, most people forget that one, but that is actually the fastest way that you
caused toxicity to your body is to inject it, okay, so if you're going to go get a vaccine or a shot
injected right into your body, that's the fastest way to kill yourself, if you're going to put poisons in your body, you
eject them. The second fastest way to get poisons in your body is to breathe them in, so when you breathe
something in it, it crosses the epithelial lighting of the lung through the alveolar space as it goes right
into the bloodstream, and quite simply, quite easily, faster than through your gut. You shouldn't be
absorbing mercury through your gut, you know, but you're absorbing, you know, things are down to
aerosol size that you could breathe them in, they could go across your lung space, so one that we
forget to work on, your main components of healing, your lung would be glutathione, I would add cortiseps
to this, cortiseps is a mushroom that is so good for your lungs, but glutathione is made into
oxidant, and we talk about the lung barrier, not just healing the lung, so cortiseps is great for
healing the lungs, but when we talk about healing the barrier itself, glutathione is the thing you
think of because it is a cellular antioxidant to those epithelial cells. We used to, you know, years ago,
we used to have patients nebulize glutathione, that's still a great way to go. It's tedious and it's
hard to do sometimes, but we highly recommend people do that at home, you buy yourself a home nebulizer,
you could get it at the drug store or on Amazon, and you could get glutathione, you typically want to
get esacetyl glutathione in the capsule form, dissolve it in a little bit of water in your nebulizer and
nebulize glutathione. Liposomal glutathione is the best way to absorb it orally, so taking oral
liposomal glutathione is your absolute best by far way to take glutathione, I guess I got a list here.
So, you'll absorb so much more glutathione through liposomal form, it'll be good and you're going to
see for everything because literally glutathione, glutathione recycling is good for the lung barrier,
the testile barrier, and the blood brain barrier, so, so important to help block those oxidizing agents
that are damaging that barrier. So, liposomal glutathione, just a huge favorite of mine.
And then the intestinal barrier, most people have heard about leaky gut,
what causes leaky gut, how to fix leaky gut, we won't spend a lot of time on this here,
but there are just so many mechanisms that lead to leaky gut, just that you can't ignore any of these.
So, memorize this slide right here, just pause this right here and just look at this.
Alcohol, a huge issue with blood brain barrier issues, I didn't talk about it, but that is the
number one, if you're going to try to heal your blood brain barrier, you guys stop drinking alcohol.
Glutin, dairy, processed foods, glutamates, GMOs are your number one damage to your gut,
that damages your epithelial lining if you've got GMO foods, fast food, medications, antibiotics,
antacids, steroids, infections, H. Pylora, H. Pylora is huge, so overlooked. H. Pylora
embalances, it's normally a part of your flora, they get embalanced very easily, it's a
gram-negative bacteria that is the cause of ulcers, but far more than that, it can go
systemically and it is one of the top five causes of cardiovascular disease because it damages
the epithelial of the vessels called the epithelial lining. So, it's a huge issue that can't be
ignored. Stress issues, hormonal issues, neurological issues, and other metabolic issues, you just
are, this is why, is you just don't ever stop working on healing these barriers, it's just,
it starts up to you stop. Here's some things that you'd find in some, some nutrients,
products that are out there. I love our product called Clear GI, that is so beneficial for healing
the gut, you'll see it below here. Now, glutamine is one of the top things for
leaky gut issues, just awarding there, do not, I do not recommend glutamine if you have cancer
or history of cancer, but other than that, it's a great gut healing thing, that's why I do like the
Clear GI because it has a little bit lower amount of glutamine and it has a little bit more than
the de-glyceride, de-glycerized licorice to calm the gut, has marshmallow, has just about everything
in that second category to help calm the gut. Making your own bone broth, I would not recommend buying
over the counter bone broth, there's just too many variables in that, but these are some really good
things to help heal your gut. We'll go over these in more detail, but these are some starting points,
some of the nutrients that I put down below in this, in this course, will are specifically for these
kind of things. Courage you to continue studying, I'm applauding you for making it as far
and know that I'm praying for you as we keep moving forward.